قبل البدء بملفاته نتوقف مع التطورات
المتسارعه في رام الله حيث افاد مراسل
الجزيره بان قوات من جيش الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي توغلت في مدينه رام الله من
محورها الغربي واقتحمت بنايه سكنيه في حي
بطن الهواء تضم شقه الاسير الطبيب ايسر
البرغوثي وشرعت في تفتيش المنزل واخذت
قياساته واحتجزت افرادا من اسرته وحققت
معهم وافاد مراسلنا بان قوات الاحتلال همت
جميع الشقق السكنيه في البنايه المحاصره
في حي بطن الهواء واجرت تحقيقا ميدانيا مع
سكانها للمتابعه ينضم الينا من رام الله
مراسل الجزيره محمد خيري محمد لك الكلمه
فيما يتعلق بابرز واخر
التطورات نعم قبل قليل قبل دقائق بالتحديد
انسحبت القوات الاسرائيليه نتحدث 15 اليه
عسكريه اسرائيليه كانت تحيط هذه العماره
التي الطبيب ايسر البرغوثي وهو معتقل لدى
القوات الاسرائيليه منذ نحو اسبوعين و
تشتبه السلطات الاسرائيليه كما تقول
بانه الشريك بتنفيذ عمليه
وقعت
بدايه هذا الشهر في وادي عيون
الحرميه شمال مدينه رام الله اذا هذا
المنزل كما علمت بعد ان حوصرت العائله
داخله تعرض لعمليات تفتيش واسعه وتخريب
ربما تظهر بعضها
هنا من قبل الجنود
الاسرائيليين و
يمكن ايضا ان نشاهد هنا على الحائط علامات
وضعها فريق الهندسه
الاسرائيلي على هذه الجدران وغيرها من
الجدران كما حفر بعض الجدران وذلك تهيئه
كما يبدو لهدم هذا المنزل او تفجير هذا
المنزل لان قوات الاحتلال تفجر منازل
منفذي العمليات من
الفلسطينيين وهذه السياسه التي يصفها
الفلسطينيون بسياسه العقاب الجماعي لكل
افراد العائله بادت سريعه وتتسارع خاصه
منذ السابع من اكتوبر حيث هدمت وفجرت
القوات الاسرائيليه عشرات المنازل في
الضفه الغربيه تشاهدون الان اثار تفتيش
المنازل وتخريب
الممتلكات التي جرت هنا على امتداد نحو
ثلاث ساعات من اقتحام هذا المنزل والمكوث
داخله من قبل الجنود الاسرائيليون كما
تشاهدون يقول السكان ان كانت هناك
يعني عمليه تعمد من اجل تخريب الممتلكات
شاهدوا معنا
هذه قياسات هذه الخطوط التي وضعها الجنود
الاسرائيليون وفريق الهندسه الاسرائيلي
على
الجدران اذا كنا خلال الساعات
الماضيه قد نقلنا ببث حي ومباشر الصور
الخاصه للاليات العسكريه الاسرائيليه التي
حاصرت هذه البنايه وقد علمت قبل قليل ان
الجيش الاسرائيلي قد حقق ميدانيا مع شقيق
الطبيب ايسر ايضا
هنا كما علمت انه جرى اقتحام المنزل ايضا
ومنازل العائله قبل نحو اسبوع ايضا وهذا
المشهد الذي تشاهدونه ايضا كان قد تمثل
هنا ايضا وفي المنازل المجاوره كما علمت
من شهود عيان خلال الفتره الماضيه ايضا
اخيرا قبل قليل ايضا اعتقلت القوات
الاسرائيليه شابا فلسطينيا بالتحديد هذا
الشاب الفلسطيني ايه ايه كان في الحي حي
بطن الهواء هنا قريبا من هذه العماره
وربما كان يعني يريد الاقتراب من المنزل
او العماره او التنقل داخل الحي الذي فرضت
عليه ايه حاله الحصار وجرى الاعتداء عليه
من قبل قوات الجيش الاسرائيلي بشده وا
علمت انه تم اقتياد الشاب الى الاعتقال من
قبل الجنود الاسرائيليين ايضا اذا هذا هو
حال منزل الطبيب ايسر البرغوثي المحتجز
لدى القوات الاسرائيليه منذ نحو اسبوعين
قال قال
لاشقاء الاسير انه يتعرض للتحقيق في هذه
الاثناء كما علمت ايضا من بعض المقربين من
العائله انهم لا يعرفون شيئا عنه ولا يسمح
بزيارته وهناك اشارات ايضا الى انه ايه
ايه ربما قد منع من لقاء المحاميين حتى
هذه الاثناء وذكرنا ان الطبيب
هو مشتبه به ثالث لدى السلطات الاسرائيليه
بتنفيذ هذه العمليه حيث كانت قد اعتقلت
ايضا طبيبا اخر وا ممرضا هذه العمليه التي
وقعت بدايه الشهر ادت الى
مقتل شاب فلسطيني واصابه ايضا شاب شابه
فلسطينيه وكلاهما يحملان الهويه
الاسرائيليه ال المشتبه بهم الثلاثه لدى
السلطات الاسرائيليه واحدهم الطبيب ايسر
العائله تقول انه يشتبه به من قبل السلطات
وليست حاليا لا يتوجد تهمه واضحه ولم يخرج
هناك قرار لا من محكمه اسرائيليه ولا من
الشرطه ولا من الجيش الاسرائيلي يعني
المعلومات شحيحه حول ما جرى فعليا يبدو
انهم قد اطلقوا النار على سياره نم الشاب
والفتاه التي كانت تحمل
لوحات ارقام اسرائيليه صفراء سنكون معك في
متابعه في حال ورود اي جديد محمد خيري
مراسل الجزيره من
رامض